il faut savoir que l'an dernier 180 deux
cas de tricherie de fraude ont été
découverts et sanctionné par l'éducation
nationale le chiffre est à peu près
stable depuis plusieurs années
la punition est variable cela va de
l'annulation du diplôme à cinq ans
d'interdiction totale de passer des
examens d'état dossier signé stéphanie
davoigneau bruno martin de face un élève
appliqué de dos un tricheur son bac lors
on reconnaît l'avoir obtenue il ya dix
ans grâce à ce style aux quatre couleurs
qu'on voulait il suffit juste de sortir
la première partie est de le faire
tourner dans votre main à l'intérieur
définition ou théorème en fonction des
matières un travail minutieux pour une
activité illégale que cet ancien lycéen
pratiquer avec assiduité
c'était mon petit travail du dimanche
soir tu es à l'ag faire une pompe et qui
marche et je croyais toujours en ma
pompe quoi je ne doutais jamais quoi et
je savais que ça fonctionnerait c'est
une sorte de paresse corps apprend
beaucoup en vue laurent a transformé sa
trousse en caverne d'ali baba du
tricheur gones cutter et caire tout est
potentiellement truc abl aujourd'hui il
est employé dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
aucun regret vous êtes un imposteur pour
le bac
pour moi c'était la réussite là mais la
méthode ça ça me
c'était pas un problème quoi quelle
valeur à un bac on a triché pour vous tu
me suis jamais posé la question quoi
pourtant voilà ce que risquer laurent
évidemment l'annulation de l'épreuve ou
de l'examen mais surtout jusqu'à cinq
ans d'interdiction de passer tout examen
universitaire ou administratif mais
qu'importe le risque laurent est
toujours aussi fier de présenter son
site internet spécial anti sèches qui
proposent même des conseils
psychologiques pour ne pas paraître
stressé et il n'est pas seul des sites
de ce genre envahissent la toile depuis
des années la justice ne s'est jamais
penché sur la question
à côté des traditionnels antisèches
apparaissent les nouvelles technologies
en région parisienne 55 fraude concerne
l utilisation de documents personnels 8
les téléphones portables 6 les changes
de brouillon entre candidats
pourtant le jour de l'examen les
consignes sont claires et ouvre sa queue
devant un bureau
les téléphones portables sont interdits
téléphones portables qui permettent de
communiquer avec l'extérieur mais aussi
de stocker des informations sous forme
de sms
et comme ils sont de plus en plus
miniaturisés ils sont de moins en moins
repérables fut pas les élèves donc
toujours leur demander ici on a un
soupçon de nous assurer qu'ils n'ont
aucun instrument et le vérifier en 2004
sur 500 1000 candidats seuls 182 ont été
sanctionnés pour fraude
mais combien de tricheurs n'ont pas été
repérés